PARTMENTINVESTIGATION INTO WHET
CONGRESSMAAETZ HAD SEXUAL RELAT.
CNN CONGRESSIONAL CORRESPONDENT
OR STORY. TONIGHT, NEW
FOGING ABOUT A
INVESTIGATION INVOLVING IDA
CONGRE.
A SOURCE FAMILIAR WITH TBE
TELLING CN BEING
STPARTMENT O
JUSTICE  SFICKING ANPRTUINCLUDI
A
ALL THINGS THE R
STRONGLY DENY.
>> IT IS A HORRIBLE ALLEGATION
AND IT IS A LIE.TIMES" IS RUNNI
17-YOLS
VERIFIABLYLE CAN MY TRAVEL
COS NOT THE
. >> Reporter: GAETZ CLAIM AND
HIS FAMILY ARE THE TARGF AN EXT
>> MARCH 16th, GOT A
TEDING A MWHEREIN A PERSOND $2
MILLION IN EXCHANGE FOMAKING
HORRIBLE SEX TRAFFICKING
ALLEGATIONAIAY.
Rr:HE P BASED
PROSORING E
EXTOIOORDING T FAMILIAR WITHHE
INVESTIGATION, THAT IS BEING
HANDLED APART FR OTHER
INVESTIGIOSSMAN ACCUSING A
FORM FEDERAL PROSECUTOR BYURIN O
NEWS.
>> HIS NAME IS DAV M.
HE W TL IN THE ERSHIP IN THE NON
A AS A
ANAW FIRM.S
ASTER OFT,F TH
MONEY THAT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
PAID TODOUW MORE
EVIDENCE OF S WORK IN THIS EXTO
>> Reporter: GAETZ CALLED ON TH
FATHERF THE FBI AND DEPARTMENT
AMERICAN PEOPLLL
REALLY GOING O ter: HIS LAW FIR
RESSMAN IS FALSE B
MR. McGEE CHIEF UN ATRTHERN
DISTRICT OA 25
RING HIS TENUR
DEPARTMENT OF
INTEGTY
ETHICAL CONDUC
CNN SOURCE DID DISCLOSE WHO
BEATED FOR
INN  G
ORTABLE, WITSUGGNGT
HAD DIERZ WHO COULD BE AT THE CR
T BY THE FBI
CARLSON DIDN'T REMEMBER THE WOM
>> I DON'T REMEMBER N E SPEAKINT
ALL.
D 'RE SAYING THERE'S AD GIRL YOD
RELATIONSHIP WITH.
T TRUE?
AND WHGIRL
WHAT ARE THEY TALKING ABT,?ERSOI
WITH A 17-YEAR-OLD.
'SN
THE INTEW  CONFUSED.
SAW THE MATT GAETZ
TERVIEW, ONE OF TH
INTERVIEWS I EVER TED.
REPUBLICAN IN TH
MINORITY LEAKE, LLED THE ALLEGA
SAID HE WAS WAITING TORN
MORE.
>> IF IT IS TRUE, WE WILL DO
SOMETHING.
RIGHT NOW,E  NOT
TR.L OF THE
INRM
>> YOU CAN SEE THE CONGRESSMAN'S
AGING ENDORSEMENT
FROM THE HOUSE MINORITY LEADER
AS THEY WAIT TO LEARN
THE INVESTIGATION.
SUPPORT FRO
MEMBER OM CAUCUS,
MEMBER ON  OF OHIO, RANKIN
COMMITTEE. STATEMENT TO CNN, SA
BELIEVED M'T OVED FROM THATOM AL
PRESSURE ON THE CONGRESSMAN FROM
FLORIDA.
>> ID.
RYAN N
ON THIS.
ATE ATTORNEY FORLO
NTY IS JOININGS. SAID SOMEE IS
YIUOTE, RECATEGORIZE
RISK  THIS EA
S CHARGES?
>>EVENING, RSEX TRAFFICKING, ES
REUI, HARBORED,
TRANSPORTED, MAINTAINED, IDED F.
ACTS,IT IS SEX AC E
AND THAT WOULD INCLUDE HOTEL
MATT GAETZ HASROTES.
ADAMANT HE NEVERDERAGE GIRL.
FEDERAL PRUTORWO
TOHOD  UNLDT
YOL ROOMS, SWAY,
N TICKETS, EXPENSES TO
IF THAT IS NOT DONE, PTORS ON TD
SEX WITH A 17-AR
HABLE UP TO 15EAIN STATE PSO TR
PUNISHABL YEARS IN STATE
ALL THESE CRIMES THAT COME WITH
IT, REGIX
DAVE, HIS FAMILY IS BEIN
IN AN SCL W
FBI'DIRECT SENSEU?
ON'TT HI
FATHER IS TELLING THWHEN
S HAVE UTT IN A
DIFFT RY.
NOT DEFENSE T
CHILD SEX TRAFFICKING.A  IN
OPINION HERE BECAUHAVEH E THIN
EVEN IF THERE IS EE
IT OUT, WE SHALL SEE, DOES NOTDE
TRAFFICKING.
YOU COULD HAVE BOTH THINGS AT
THE SAME TIME.
F THIS IA
PRE S
REPRESENTING AO IS
ALLEGEDLY N THIS CASE,
BEFORE THEY FILESUIT THAT
ES OF
JUE APNTN
SIX HSS NOT LIKEY'RE GO
LEAK SOMETHING TE
PROSECUTORS IF YOU DON'T HAVE.
THE PROSECUTORY HAVE
ARENTLY.>>DERATIGATION
AS YOU CORRECT O, IT BEGAN IN T
Y GENERAL BILL BARR.
WHO YOU MAKEF THAT
>> YEAH.
INVESTIGATN IGHTO POIND
BARR ANDALTRUMP.THAT WOULD RUIN
TH TAKEN DURING  THEATER
THFI
INVESTIGATION, HE STORIT
THEYD IT, HAA
THIS IS POLIL ME
WITCH HU.ALLEGATION HE S OMOM I
D BALL
THAT'SRA.
I CAN ASSUREOUWOLF, IFENER ISSSU
AND ALLEGATI